on a tous ces partis pour les 5 bonnes
nouvelles de la semaine admissibles dans
pas moins de 40 universités aux états
unis tupac mosley a décidé d'étudier le
génie informatique de l'université du
tennessee
cette carte d'assurance maladie sera
testée jusqu'à la fin du mois de mai
2020 dans les alpes-maritimes et dans le
rhône
la particularité de ce train est de ne
jamais toucher les rails on dit même
qu'il vole grâce aux forces et pulse
yves entre deux pôles dément semblables
après avoir converti même les plus
réfractaires au rangement marie condos
sort un livre à destination des enfants
nommé fenty cette marque de luxe est
déjà vendue à paris depuis quelques
jours c'est la fin des bonnes nouvelles
à la semaine prochaine